branches simply a delicious combination
of breakfast and lunch and for me it's
all about getting up late and having a
wonderful lazy start to the weekend with
fantastic food
more exciting than breakfast and a lot
more enjoyable to cook brunch is ideal
for sharing
first up my simple and delicious
frittata eggs are great they are so
versatile and once you've mastered how
to cook them trust me the door then
opens to a wide range of delicious
options
this is like a triple omelette but a lot
more ingredients than a normal mess
let's start off with some lovely smoked
bacon slice the bacon bacon in
no salt
a little touch of pepper start off on a
high heat get that bacon really nice and
crispy otherwise you just boil the bacon
and it's got that soft unpleasant
texture in the potato
turn down the gas and now start adding
your veg roughly chop a red pepper and
add it to the pan
the peppers and the bacon take the
longest so they've always got to go in
first
now sucker them off
the peppers have been cooked now from
that sort of rendered fat in the bacon
and then
you spring onions just Bunch them up
slice them I want them on an angle
so they come like little green diamonds
spring onions in
now for the eggs
cracking the eggs
for that size pan
seven or eight eggs
I'm Gonna Fill it right to the very top
and more importantly when I turn this
out
I want it like a gateau nice and thick
so slice through and seal those
wonderful verbs
[Music]
I'm gonna season the eggs
with some Parmesan cheese be quite
generous because it has a really nice
saltiness
[Music]
fresh ground pepper and then whisk
whisk up those eggs nicely
[Music]
then add peas to the pan
and to give the dish a wonderful
aromatic freshness some fragrant chopped
basil I want to chop that sort of
roughly
because I want to see those flecks of
green going in
I weren't looking charming and how many
times have you seen a dull omelette
frittatas in my mind really help
encapsulate the magic of having
Savory eggs cooked beautifully
but with texture now just before we add
the eggs
got this
beautiful little ghost cheese and it's
strong and powerful so I want to slice
it
into little chunks
and then just
have it dotted around I want to discover
these little pockets of creamy goat's
cheese now slowly
the eggs
[Music]
fill that right up
I'm getting spoon now just let all that
egg go down to the bottom
bring it back up the boil
and sort of clean around the sides and
then some of this delicious salty
creamy goat cheese over the top
yeah
I want it melting like a
perfect slice
cheese on toast
nice now from there turn the grill on
for four to five minutes
foreign
[Music]
just looking at that
delicious
take a little paring knife and just make
sure
it's released
from the sides just take your panel
tab
that will hopefully release the frittata
from the bottom of the pan
bought over the pan turn that gently
and just
Shake say a little prayer and lift off
[Music]
now
from there
on there it's there look
now
through
you can see how soft and creamy that is
in the center
that goat cheese are just melting almost
like a little sauce inside so exciting
but more importantly it's so easy to do
it's got texture it's got creaminess and
that for me will beat any omelette for
brunch so with a stack of hot buttered
toast and a steaming pot of coffee this
easy frittata Turns The Humble egg into
the perfect dish for kicking off the
weekend
[Music]
eggs are really versatile protein packed
and delicious here are three more of my
favorite recipes to give your brunches a
tasty twist
first up North African eggs
foreign
to a hot pan and Fry finely chopped
onions and red and green peppers
[Music]
then chop garlic
and chili
and cook until softened
chilies work brilliantly with eggs
giving the dish a lovely hot cake
next add fresh chopped tomatoes then
cumin seeds and Fry till the seeds are
fragrant and the tomatoes are lovely and
soft
season
next make wells in your spicy sauce and
crack in your eggs
then cover and cook on a low heat for
five minutes so the whites are set and
the yolks are still lovely and runny
to finish slice bring onions
and coriander and simply sprinkle over
fresh spicy and deliciously different
easy North African eggs ready in under
20 minutes and it's worth getting up
late for
next eggs made super indulgent for
brunch cheat souffle with three cheeses
[Music]
mix together flour
sugar
baking powder and season
make it well in the center
then simply beat six eggs together
pour into the well and whisk into the
flour then whisk in the milk making the
mixture lovely and light next add the
three cheeses cottage cheese grated
monterey jack or cheddar
[Music]
and cream cheese
and then for extra richness knobs of
butter
then butter a baking dish
pour in your Rich cheesy cheeks souffle
mix
now put in a medium oven and bake for 40
minutes until Rich golden and puffed to
Perfection
a stunning fuss-free souffle that's
ideal for brunch
[Music]
my next easy egg dish is a salty and
succulent prawn and feta omelette
[Music]
pour olive oil into a hot pan add
chopped tomatoes
spring onions and Fry
season
[Music]
next add cooked prawns and a Sprinkle of
chili flakes to give it a lovely kick of
heat cook through and set aside next
beat four eggs
add olive oil to your frying pan and
pour in the eggs
sprinkle on freshly chopped oregano
which works brilliantly with eggs
then spoon over the spicy prawns
crumple over creamy feta cheese and
grill for a couple of minutes
this is eggs to the nth degree packed
with different tastes textures and
flavors all working wonderfully together
perfect